-Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know from movies such as
"Downsizing," "The Menu,"
and the limited series
"Watchmen"
and "Big Little Lies."
She stars in "The Whale," which
is in select theaters tomorrow,
and opens nationwide
December 21st.
Let's take a look.
-I really hate you for putting
me through this again,
you know that?
Those last few months
before Alan,
I'd come over here, shake him,
scream at him,
just trying to get him
to [ Bleep ] eat something.
God, that was awful.
-It was awful for me too.
-Yeah, well you weren't the one
who had to identify
his body all bloated.
-They wouldn't let me.
I wasn't family.
-Please welcome back to the
show, our friend Hong Chau.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello, Hong,
welcome back to the show!
-I'm so happy to see you.
-I'm so happy to be back.
I was -- I was telling people
backstage
I was so nervous
the first time I was here,
and you were so great
and so nice.
-All right, great, and now
you're feeling --
hopefully you're feeling
relaxed and ready to go.
-Yes, it wasn't you.
I was afraid that you were
going to ask me if I had
played any pranks on set.
-Oh, yeah.
Are you not a prankster?
-No.
-Yeah.
-No, that would have been bad.
"Hey, mom and dad, I just booked
this really wonderful role,
but I got fired because I just
could not help myself
from putting shaving cream in
Matt Damon's shoes."
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah, that's right.
-That is true.
So, "downsizing" was, I believe
the first time
many of us saw you,
and since then
your career has been,
I would imagine "easier"
is the wrong word.
but certainly parts
are coming easier.
Do you still remember the time
before "Downsizing?"
What it was like to be an actor?
-Oh, yeah, absolutely.
It took me 10 years to become
an overnight success.
So I definitely --
I still have the pay stub
from when I was a cater waiter.
-Really?
You kept your
cater waiter pay stub?
-Yes, as a reminder
of that nightmare.
[ Laughter ]
And I never returned to it.
-You went to B.U.
what were you studying at B.U.?
-I actually studied
film production.
-So you thought you'd
be behind the camera?
-Yeah, yeah.
I never wanted to be an actor.
I actually was really
introverted and had a hard time
just talking to people, so I --
-Yeah, so that's hard
for actors.
Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's a skill.
-And, so, what happened?
When was the shift that you
realized
"Oh, acting's what
I want to do now?"
-Um, I just recognized that,
you know,
I needed to work on myself,
so I started to take public
speaking classes,
and then that led
to improv classes,
and I wanted to barf before
every improv class,
but I forced myself to go
and here I am.
-Here you are.
It all worked out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is a film, almost
recognizable,
that's Brendan Fraser in the
clip,
and he's playing a man
struggling with obesity.
You're his caretaker.
This film has received
a ton of attention.
It was at Venice.
What's it like being in a Darren
Aronofsky film, no less,
that's receiving
so much attention?
-Absolutely incredible.
We all had
so many doubts going in.
You know, every movie is a big
leap of faith,
but we shot this in February
of 2021 during Covid,
before vaccines were available,
so that was still
a very scary time.
And then Darren Aronofsky is
this really acclaimed director,
and you have no idea how an
auteur director is going to be
when you work with him, and he
was just so sweet and open,
and then Brendan Fraser
is just an angel.
You've worked with him,
you know.
-I have.
I worked with him on a film that
received less attention.
[ Laughter ]
I worked with him on a film
called
"Journey to the Center
of the Earth."
-Mm-hmm.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Don't patronize me.
[ Laughter ]
But he is so lovely.
-He is.
-He is so lovely.
And this, you know, I'm
wondering, had you known him?
Were you somebody when you --
were you watching
Brendan Fraser movies?
-No, I actually had not seen
any of his movies
prior to working with him.
And normally I would do some
research,
but I just had a baby
right beforehand, so, you know,
you know how it is.
-Yeah, absolutely.
And, so, you showed up on set
and you knew Brendan Fraser
was a guy named Brendan Fraser
and that's about it?
-That's -- I mean,
I knew he was --
-Tight, right.
-You know.
I knew he was a hunk,
and was famous, and all of that,
but yeah, it's weird,
I'm definitely in the right
age group to be a superfan.
But I'm glad I got to meet him
the way that I did, yeah.
-This film is in Venice.
Have you been to Venice before
with anything?
-With "Downsizing," actually.
-Oh, nice.
How was your Venice experience
this time?
-It was my second time, but
the first time with Brendan.
-Yep.
-And that was amazing because
the audience gave him like,
a six, seven minute
standing ovation.
It was really, really moving.
I'm so glad that audiences
get to see him again
in this really incredible role.
-You also were in a fantastic
film that's still in theatres
called "The Menu," and you were
great in "The Menu."
And we're big fans of
"The Menu" at the show
because it was co-written by one
of our writers, Seth Reiss --
-
with his writing partner
Will Tracy.
And was this a role when you
first read the script,
did you think that this was
a perfect role for you?
-Yes, because the description
was
"Severe Scandinavian woman."
[ Laughter ]
-That's you.
-I got this. Yes.
-So what happens?
what is the path?
I guess the director, at some
point says, you know,
that part's less -- I mean,
by the way, you know,
Reiss writes stuff all the time
that we ignore here,
as well, so...
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I did ask to cut
some of my lines.
-Did you really?
-I did.
-Yeah, he does overwrite,
doesn't he?
[ Laughter ]
-yeah.
It's a problem.
-I mean, I would li-- If you
could come in and give our staff
a tutorial on how to
cut his stuff.
-Give me a red pen, I'm ready.
[ Laughter ]
-And, so, you had --
we were talking about,
you had a baby during covid.
-Yes. I found out I was pregnant
a few days before
the lockdown happened,
and it was actually a really
nice time for me,
despite all of the horror
going on.
-Yeah, I mean, there is
something about being able
to, you know, remove yourself
from the daily grind
during a time when it is, you
know, I think,
you should be able to,
like, nest and prepare.
-It was so nice.
I didn't feel like I was missing
out on anything.
I could just ignore all of my
emails,
and just not pick up my phone.
It was great.
-That's great.
And she's almost 2 now?
-She just turned 2.
-Oh, my God, fantastic.
So the personality I would
imagine is popping.?
-Yes, she's --
she's singing her ABCs,
and "Twinkle Twinkle
Little Star,"
and afterwards, she says, "'ank
you, everybody, 'ank you."
[ Laughter ]
-Where did she learn --
Oh, she's not going to need
public speaking classes.
She's ready to go.
What is there -- do you have any
work yet
that you think are gonna be --
how old is your daughter
gonna have to be
before she sees anything?
I feel like I can't think of
anything that's not like,
17-years-old.
-A long time.
So, if there's a family movie
that somebody's looking
for a severe Scandinavian woman
to star in...
[ Laughter ]
I'm your girl.
-Have you gone on your head shot
now, put special skills,
"Plays severe Scandinavian?"
-I should, I should,
thanks, sir, for that.
-Did you -- wait,
so "The Whale," did you --
'cause I imagine you don't have
to audition much anymore,
but did you, for "The Whale?"
-I did.
-Wow.
-I did have to audition
for "The Whale."
Because I'm highfalutin now
and I don't have to do that.
but I did have to because it's
Darren Aronofsky.
-It's Darren Aronofsky,
he's very particular.
Obviously it shows up
on the screen.
When he knows what he wants,
he gets it.
But how -- In this day and age
is that something
where you have to like,
film yourself, or...?
-It was very difficult with the
baby,
because I couldn't use my
non-mommy voice with her.
So whenever I would try to do
the audition tape,
I'd use my deeper adult voice
and she would start crying,
and so you'd hear this crying
baby in the background.
And we managed to get one clean
take,
and that was the one
that we sent off.
-Yeah, 'cause based on the clip
I don't think that scene would
have the same power if you were
using a mommy voice.
[ Laughter ]
-Very, very different.
-And what about the holidays?
Are you --
do you guys have plans?
Are you excited?
-Um, I'm just ready to rest,
I feel like I've been
really busy working.
I just wrapped up a movie
in New Orleans,
which is my hometown, so I was
very excited to do that.
-Is there added pressure when
you're working in your hometown?
Do you have to, like, the manage
your family and friends?
-Well, no, it's more about
people asking for
restaurant recommendations.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's oppressive when they --
-It is, like, "What's the best
Vietnamese restaurant?"
or "What's the best --" you
know, whatever you go to.
-yeah, 'cause you don't want to
work with people all day,
and then know the next morning
you're gonna find out
what they think about you
as a concierge.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-They're like, "Eh, I guess we
have different tastes, Hong."
[ Laughter ]
"Not my favorite."
2 years old, does your daughter
have an awareness of Christmas?
Do you feel like that,
you at least have?
-Well, I do read "Elmo's 12 Days
of Christmas" to her
over and over and over.
-gotcha.
-So I think she knows that.
-Got it.
Is Elmo her favorite
of the "Sesame Street"?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-well, actually Abby is now --
-Oh, yeah.
-Scooching up on the list.
But I wasn't familiar with Abby
when I was growing up.
-I think Abby came after our
time, yeah.
I had an interesting thing
happen,
which is I have some friends who
work at "Sesame Street,"
and when my second was --
-[ Gasps ] Can I get on?
-What?
-Can I get on?
-I'm sorry, we're not taking --
[ Laughter ]
We'd love for you
to get yourself on tape.
[ Laughter ]
We'd love to get you on there.
But I did -- we, uh...
so friends of mine work there,
and when my second was born,
they obviously know the
psychology of the first,
maybe might be intimidated
by the second.
And, so, they did this really
sweet thing where may had Elmo
record a video saying, like
"Hey, Ash, you're about to have
a baby brother.
Congratulations!"
And it was so -- and my son who
was 2 at the time,
watched it, and his
reaction was horror.
[ Laughter ]
Like, I think every part of him
was like,
why does this [ Bleep ] Puppet
know so much about me?
[ Laughter ]
It was like,
"Well, he knows my name.
He knows mom's having a ba--
I don't like this guy."
So just know, it cuts both ways.
Cuts both ways.
Hong, thank you so much
for being here.
Congrats on the film.
-Thank you.
-Happy holidays and come back
again soon.
Hong Chau, everybody.
"The Whale" is in select
theaters tomorrow
and opens nationwide
December 21st.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."